harcelé par gêne les shadoks risquant le
tout pour le tout vont partir dans le
cosmos avec la lune pour chercher une
terres plus hospitalières
il allait s'enfoncer encore une fois
dans les profondeurs de l'espace et cela
c'est une siège lui crever déglingué
rafistolé qui pouvait les laisser en
plan n'importe quand franchement c'était
risque
jadot coûts avaient mis au point un
système de propulsion ou maire de son
invention
naturellement il fallait couper mais ça
la population s'en chargerait on bat les
malheureux chador que prisonnier
voyaient d'un assez mauvais oeil vous
pensez bien leurs derniers espoirs de
délivrance son volet ça qu'est ce que
vous voulez
c'est pas de notre faute
une versa une dernière larmes sur cette
terre ne connaîtrai jamais qui est la
population put invités à pomper c'est
alors que commence à la difficulté la
population de pompey pas la population
leuglay parmi la population refusait de
poule
la population était sur le dos les pas
en l'air et son pichet telle mentalité
c'était donc ça la nouvelle génération
de shadocks lunaire des shadoks qui dont
ces jours où s'écrivaient des pages
parmi les plus grandioses de leur
histoire s'asseyait dessus mais ce
n'était pas de leur faute
les shadoks 9 était tombé malade il
avait attrapé le mal de lune